so i'm rebecca goldstein and his owen
mention i was
as a very good Jewish girl and in fact
come from a very Orthodox family so the
kind in which ambition among girls was
not even a problem to conceive of it was
inconceivable and my path was pretty
clear then that a girl could even that
they my parents even had to deal with an
ambitious girl I mean it was
inconceivable to them it was just I mean
the most you know perhaps I would go to
college and become a kindergarten
teacher perhaps you know but um I they
allowed me strangely enough to go to the
public library we were very very poor we
didn't know any books but before the
Sabbath every Friday we would get our
reading material and they allowed me
free range and I got a book between 2nd
and 3rd graders and some are called
our friendly Adam and that was like what
you know the world out there is nothing
the way it seems to be there there are
no colors there are no you know it's all
and there are these heroes they're
called scientists they're called
business and somehow they are able to
get out there and they were able to
describe the way the world really is and
I my greatest hope was that I would
someday meet a scientist and be able to
talk to the camera
and ask them how they did this how they
could possibly get outside their own
lines-- and discover the real nature of
reality so it but you know then I was
just reading as much as I could about
these things and hoping that I would
meet a scientist um the the next thing I
read that that rocked my my little world
was probably about 12 years old my
parents still hadn't caught on to the
fact that the library was the most
dangerous place in the world that I was
um Bertrand Russell's why I am NOT a
Christian and it's so good it works on
Jews so uh you know and for those who
say that people in this room and Beyond
who write atheist books are just you
know preaching to the choir that it
doesn't make a difference
false false false you know especially
for young people who are asking these
questions you know that that that
article
yeah it just completely changed my mind
and I was going to get to college one
way or the other when I did get to
college you know it was again philosophy
was not something to major in it was it
was known in my world as very very
dangerous and subversive so and besides
I wanted to be not just to meet a
scientist but then at that point to be a
scientist and to be a physicist and I
started out with that intention and it
was quantum mechanics it was quantum
mechanics that did it I kept going to my
professor and asking him you know what
does it mean what is it saying about our
world and he was of the school of just
shut up and and calculate and um then he
finally said to me I was in Columbia why
don't you go talk to one of the
philosophers they asked this sort of
question so I went and I spoke to Sidney
Morgan Bessel
we had about an 8 hour conversation we
went out to dinner we spoke late into
the night and at the end he convinced me
that I should go into philosophy of
science and I I live to forgive him
but I and then I you know I went on I
went to Princeton I was very and I want
you to do foundations of quantum
mechanics that was the thing that had
gotten me interested in philosophy when
I got to Princeton at that time they
really was nobody to work with on that
the person in philosophy of science was
Carl temple temple wonderful man but he
was not willing to work on foundations
of quantum mechanics and I was I was
floundering and then I read Tommy Cole
Tommy who was there and Tom I read Tom
Nagle's what does it like to be a bat
and I this was a problem that had really
bothered me how does that you know I was
a confirmed materialist but how was it
that it feels like something to be this
brain why does it feel like something
and and here you know and he was putting
it into a language that people I
appreciate it I thought he was making
the problem quite clear and I and I
didn't work with him I now look back in
and I see that my move away from
religion has come in stages and that was
he had another stage and in the process
anyways he got the doctor it became a
philosopher I don't know how I became a
novelist to tell you the truth you know
it still surprises me I was always
thinking meta philosophically my
philosophy seems to me such a strange
subject I kind of wandered into her
because of problems and tried to
physics and what is so impressed me
about philosophy and philosophical
conversations are the intuitions that
people bring to bear on philosophical
core intuitions deep down intuitions
about free will or about the objectivity
of moral judgments or certain things
that they are unwilling to forego and
they'll change everything around them
but keep those core intuitions and so
that when you get down to it
you know you can make a lot of headway
with people who share your intuitions
and not so much with people who don't
share your intuitions and that that
aspect of it has the character aspect of
it the fact that you know in philosophy
we're probably either dealing with proto
scientific questions we haven't yet
reached the science and so we're just
kind of floundering or maybe they're
really not empirically resolvable you
know that is something that's open to me
I don't know what these philosophical
questions are but whatever they are they
leave a lot of room for one's entire
character to kind of bubble up and
provide one with intuitions so that
aspect has interest in me so much and
there was no place to deal with that in
philosophy and it drove me to write
these philosophical novels as a way of
trying to show how character is in play
these philosophical intuitions that's
the best explanation elation I can give
for why I sometimes write these these
philosophical novels and you know and
sometimes go back and write other things
I love me I published my first novel of
mind body problem when I was very young
and basically my philosophical career
with it
it was like you know when in the day
went out you know when I had entered in
it was hard enough to be a young woman
in philosophy of science you know always
the only woman now at least there's
someone another woman but he's the only
woman in the room especially yeah when
it was full of you-know-what anything a
philosophy of science philosophy of math
was also one of my major and
mathematical logical men at one of my
major interest so but you know and then
you publish a novel a sexy novel you
might as well go around with a sign
saying I am I'm not serious
frivolous creature so you know anyway
that will that's how I ruin my career
and what am I most what can I one of my
interest in having my mind changed about
um so many things philosophy of math is
a major issue for me and it is the kind
of thing that sticks yes yes of them the
man you know I wrote a book on girdles
incompleteness theorems girls seem to
think that his theorems may be implied
is too strong a term but strongly
suggested mathematical realism I'm quite
convinced by that I would like to be
unconvinced by that I'd also like to be
unconvinced of my view that we that
philosophical issues can't be resolved
and we're basically coming at it with
these you know with our whole world
being with our
in her life and that they are you know
deep in our core I would like to be able
to talk to somebody who has very
different intuitions than I do
and either convince them of mine or be
convinced by theirs and see that their
progress can actually be made in
philosophy I'm not convinced two can be
you